anticipation is building in Rome and so
are the crowds the Via della con chile
etzioni was filled with tourists
believers and onlookers this morning
they're all flocking to st. Peter's
Square ahead of tomorrow's ceremony a
canonization will be attended by dozens
of heads of state and by pilgrims from
around the world it's thought that over
a million might attend many are from
Poland John Paul the second was hugely
popular in his native country college me
we loved our hope we were the
beatification in Rome and now we've come
for the canonization as well he did not
the things that's it we owe so much to
him we're going to pray for him pilgrims
are coming by train bus and even
motorbike like this group which has
brought along its own priests two of the
20th century's most prominent Pope's are
being made Saints John Paul the second
visited more countries than any of his
predecessors and enjoyed great
popularity John the 23rd launched the
Second Vatican Council which made long
overdue reforms to the Catholic Church
in the early 1960s their canonization
will be broadcast in more than 20
countries live and in 3d a reminder that
it will be a show as well as a solemn
ceremony